foreign
for CBS deals and whether you're looking
for a Father's Day gift or a little
something for yourself we have a few
items that might make shopping a little
bit easier and all at exclusive
discounts to start shopping now scan the
QR code on your screen or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Craig
Smith joins us now with more Craig good
morning icons good morning this already
Jeff is really mad over there but tell
us hold up a second just hold up just a
second I feel like I should say the
Bears I feel like I should do that with
this first this is all about Chicago yes
so our first item happy to meet you if
you've never heard of this brand if
you've had steak at a wonderful
Steakhouse in Chicago New York or Las
Vegas you've tested this brand right now
this is two and a half pounds two and a
half pounds of Italian beef plus the
eight rolls this is the Difference Maker
Dana right there the au jus okay dip the
sandwich in there it's ready to go and
it is absolutely spectacular CBS deals
price on our happy to meet you beef
we've got it at 33 percent off get all
of this for under a hundred dollars
Father's Day guys this is a great way to
spend Father's Day right here chef this
is good yummy stuff right yummy stuff I
got a feeling Jessica's gonna be coming
over in a couple seconds here
um this one I need love this not have to
be Father's Day no this is key smart
anybody you know that always misplaces
their keys they're underneath the sofa
you left them in the kitchen you don't
know where the heck they are this is key
Smart IT pairs with your iPhone the app
that's already on there it's called the
find my app right and this allows you to
Ping from your phone to the key smart so
you can actually find it when it's on
the sofa for people that have an Apple
Watch same kind of thing where when I
find my Apple watch yeah and it all of a
sudden dings yeah and you can actually
there's the ding sound right here so I'm
using my phone it dings the key smart
I'm able to find my keys and it works
the other way as well so if you can't
find the phone you have the keys you can
press the button
but it's a tile I don't think it's that
one I love it works a similar fashion
and there's hair here's how it holds
your keys too so it's kind of a Swiss
army knife style yeah you could put 14
keys in here so get rid of that jingling
in your pocket key smart
how much is this one this is 20 off
cbsdeals.com 39.99 I love this one isn't
that good Jeff Jeff's gonna keep eating
we're going to keep moving
enjoy the auju nothing says summer like
a great barbecue right we've got the
grill time Tailgater here this is a on
the go charcoal burning outdoor grill
for you
on the go so we're thinking picnic
camping tailgating for the concert
tailgating for the big game that you're
going to this is portable to take
anywhere and I take the top off here
look at the size of this girl oh my God
this is I actually shot a video of my
Terrace in New York that's a great point
for it so it's great for those smaller
places you can't have the big charcoal
grill this uses ten percent of the
charcoal of a regular Grill and now you
can have grilling and even when this is
fired up Dana this outer shell here is
stays cool you can pick this up move
right around this you're going to love
this for the summertime and the grilling
40 off the grill time Grill we have is
for you at
119.99. I will okay you never invite me
over but I'll get it I will invite you
over if you get this for me then we'll
get the yeah we'll be all set a lot of
beef it feeds five so I'll come over too
it'll be good all right last up our
shower Target now we're gonna have a
little bit of fun all right summertime
is the time we get Outdoors we get dirty
you're walking off the beach you've gone
under the hike you're covered in Grime
and gross stuff and you want to change
right yeah wrapping the towel around
yourself and trying to change out of a
bathing suit have you tried that many
times how does that work out does not
work out well this is the shower toga
you simply step in oh God
cinch it around your waist and there's
two little slits here in the side you
can get your hands inside and you can
easily change out of the wet gross
clothes we're also going to include the
shower to go nozzle this screws onto a
water bottle and you can rinse yourself
off I have dirty pets my dogs get gross
all the time when we go
you can see how I wear this or cinched
around my waist we have the mannequin
here to show ladies how you're going to
be able to get out of that swimsuit now
you leave the beach you can easily get
changed get cleaned up has the slits on
the side so I can change out of my
clothes without showing everybody or
everything I thought this was lingerie
it is not lingerie it may be for some
people it's not designed to be lingerie
price on this as well you can find all
four of these great products this is
51.99 also at the shower toga 34 off as
part of our special with CBS deals
fantastic thank you very much and of
course we partner with all of these
companies to get these deals to buy
anything you saw today scan that QR code
on your screen or head over to
cbsdeals.com